what's going on guys this is Rob and
this is my pitch for Wolverine in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so first
things first the basis behind all of
this is Hydra and I know people are
going to say oh my God hydra's been done
to death has it though because by the
end of this I think you're going to be
like yeah man that should be how it's
done in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
just hear me out this has three plot
threads each one's very very easy to
follow I'll explain to you what the plot
thread is and then I'll tell you why it
works plot thread number one Hydra
creates weapons Plus what's weapons Plus
in Marvel Comics weapons plus was
introduced to us in new X-Men issue
number 128 and the idea behind it is
that it was initially a United States
government program and then eventually a
joint venture between the United States
CIA and Canada's Department H but the
overall goal here was to basically
contain and control the mutant threat
and in fact in Marvel Comics Captain
America was weapon one project rebirth
he was supposed to be the first in a new
line of super soldiers that were tached
for the purpose of containing and
controlling mutants World War II was a
field test if Captain America proved to
be successful which he was and if he had
returned to the United States at the end
of the war which he didn't his mind
would have been wiped and he would have
gone forward as the first in a new line
of super soldiers to stand against the
rising mutant population in the United
States we would take that concept and we
would modify it what we would say here
is that as we know in Captain America
the Winter Soldier Hydra was secretly
taking control of Shield the problem is
that while they did want their own line
of Captain Americas that could basically
do hydra's bidding Steve Rogers was
believed to be dead we know he was alive
and Frozen in a block of ice but Hydra
didn't know that and so there was no way
to extract the super soldier serum from
his blood at the same time Abraham ersin
was the only person to have the formula
for the super soldier serum but he died
in Captain America 1 so there was no way
to create new super soldiers that would
be identical to Captain America and so
as part of a series of just extremely
covert projects that were maintained at
black sites weapons plus was introduced
as a series of programs to create
various versions of super soldiers the
great thing about this is you can take a
lot of what's already in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and just roll it into
weapons plus the most obvious example
here would be Bucky Barnes right but
what you could also do is you could say
like the entirety of the Red Room the
Black Widow program that's all weapons
plus you could say even that like the
purple man zebidah killgrave giving his
age and the time at which Hydra Was
Defeated he basically gained his powers
through the experiments of his parents
long before Hydra was defeated in
Captain America the Winter Soldier so
you could say that like the purple man
from Jessica Jones was a weapons plus
product but that's the first plot thread
Hydra creates weapons plus plot thread
number two Hydra creates
adamantium accidentally so here's how
this would work in Black Panther 1 one
of the things that we learned is that
the only way to attain vibranium was
within wakanda itself unless you were
someone like ulyses claw who managed to
somehow sneak in and then escape with
your life albeit with a little bit of
vibranium there was no conceivable way
to get your hands on it but we learned
in Black Panther 2 that a vibranium
deposit exists in the Atlantic Ocean so
what we say here is that at some point
along the line either as part of weapons
Plus or some other project that Hydra
was working on they were trying to find
vibranium they learned that it existed
in wakanda but they knew there was no
way to get in there but they discovered
vibranium in the Atlantic but much like
the opening scene from Black Panther 2
when you had that group trying to get
vibranium that Hydra was attacked the
difference is that Hydra managed to
escape with a tiny little piece of
vibranium and so what they did is they
took that Shard of vibranium and they
handed it over to a guy named myON mlan
now why am I using that name because in
Marvel Comics myON mlan is the guy who
created adamantium so a little bit of
History here right kind of back away
from this the for a second in this
Wolverine video let's talk about comic
book history so when Captain America was
first introduced he had literally a
shield in the shape of an iron but
during World War II he went to wakanda
and fought alongside the wakandans
against the forces of raml and the
Germans during this time he realized
that wakandans were using circular
Shields which could be used offensively
in the sense that you could throw it or
it could be used defensively in that it
could block things not only that at the
end of The Campaign as thanks for
helping the wakandans he was given a
tiny piece of vibranium and so he goes
back to the United States and he orders
the federal government to create a new
Shield that's round and to make it out
of vibranium this entire project was
handed over to myON mlan again we're
still talking about the comic books here
myON mlan actually fell asleep during
the process and when he woke up he
basically discovered a kind of uh
vibranium iron hybrid right called Proto
adamantium but in an attempt to recreate
this Proto adamantium he created true
through adamantium now Proto adamantium
is stronger right I mean that's why
Wolverine's claws cannot cut through
Captain America's shield but what we
would do here is we would more or less
copy this process absent the whole thing
with Captain America that Hydra was able
to escape with a tiny piece of vibranium
and they ended up handing it over to
myON mlan the best metal urist that
Hydra had working for them and their
task was find a way to duplicate this
the problem was he couldn't duplicate it
but during the process he ended up
creating a new metal that was more
durable than vibranium but did not have
any of the sound absorbing properties of
vibranium and he ended up calling it
adamantium now the most logical question
to ask here is that if adamantium has
been made here then why haven't we seen
it at any point in the history of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe well the first
answer to that question is that myON
mlan was only able to make so much
adamantium right just a relatively
limited amount of it given The Shard of
vibranium that was available to to him
the second reason is because adamantium
has to stay in a liquid state the
instant it hardens you can never get it
back to a liquid state again right so if
Hydra was going to use it they better
make it good right this is like a single
use case material so that's plot thread
number two Hydra creates adamantium by
accident plot thread number three James
howlet and this is probably going to be
the most divisive part of this pitch the
healing factor of James howlet did not
act when he was a little kid his origin
as you traditionally know it in Marvel
Comics and even in the Wolverine Origins
film is not the origin that we're going
with we're going with the origin from
the Ultimate Universe so here's the way
this would work in the MCU right this is
my pitch for James how this this I think
is probably one of the coolest parts
right here's what we would do James
howed is a guy who's part of like a
Black Ops wet workor team that operates
through the CIA right they're called
team X right similar to what you saw in
Wolverine Origins but not crappy but
this team is solid they're the best
there is at what they do these guys will
take out any Target it doesn't matter
what it is if a face comes across their
desk that guy gets killed here's a
kicker to all of this they were
operating as agents of Hydra they simply
didn't know it because Hydra was
secretly controlling shield and while
they were not getting their orders from
Shield per se they were getting their
orders from the CIA and as we know Hydra
didn't simply just have agents in Shield
they had agents in the upper echelon of
the federal government and throughout
every single intelligence organization
which meant that the various targets
that team X was taking out we could say
this takes place during like the 60s and
70s right during the Cold War basically
that the various targets that team X was
taking out they were Hydra targets they
were people that were a threat to Hydra
now because team X was so good at what
they did Hydra decided to bring them in
as their newest test subjects for
weapons plus which is the weapon X
Program weapon 10 whatever you want to
call it and as you would expect with a
program like this they were drawing
blood and they were scanning their
bodies and so on and so forth but Hydra
comes to the realization that James
howlet codenamed wolver rain when he was
on the team that he has a gene in his
body that does not match anything in the
human genome they don't know what it is
and so they activate it boom he has a
healing factor and that's when they
realize this is our assassin this is the
guy that we use our adamantium on this
guy can heal from anything take this
indestructible metal Bond it to a
skeleton brainwash him and send him out
as an assassin such as it is he ended up
escaping the brainwashing process even
after the adamantine was Bond into his
body and effectively took off and Hydra
just wasn't able to find him again for
any number of reasons right you could
just chalk it up to like his Black Ops
training that he's very good at staying
hidden but again this is all just kind
of an idea that I have let me know what
you guys think about this down in the
comments section I'm really kind of
curious I think it's cool it's obviously
got holes and it would have to be
tightened up a little bit but let me
know what you guys think but with that
being said we're going to bring this to
an end and I will catch you all later
peace